we look at ourselves as a as a family
you know even though we have people in
the u.s in
in asia pack in europe still we try to
make it as a family we keep sure that
you know the whatever information we
keep it available to our people so they
understand you know what's happening in
the company what's the progress so we
build internal trust and that internal
trust builds excitement and motivation
and they convey that to our customers to
get them to trust us
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i have with me ruben
braham vp marketing of cyberant
reuben is an experienced marketing
executive with an extensive background
in building brands and developing sales
pipeline via structured demand
generation that includes an abm strategy
he has been with many key organizations
like sale point checkpoint converse
microsoft and formula and more recently
as vice president of marketing for
cyberend
ruben specialized in b2b enterprise
marketing for technology products with
focus on cyber security during the last
10 years he built managed and scaled
marketing teams globally and brings a
rich knowledge of sales business
development building partner channels
and technology alliances
reuben braham welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm fine michael thank you for having me
today
thank you for having me today i'm really
excited to have you here and talking
about marketing especially in b2b
enterprise and the cyber world
so much art
it's so similar to you know art and then
the way that you're thinking about you
know people and you're thinking about
businesses and what they care about and
what you offer and especially in the
world that is changing every single day
and the offering is changing there's a
lot of competition so it's i'm really
excited to dig deep into these worlds
with you you're you're an expert in
marketing and there's no other way to
put it you've done some incredible
things just a few of them converse and
checkpoint and today's cyber and as vp
and marketing so a lot of really
interesting stories that i'm sure that
we can cover here but we only have 20
minutes i want to get deep into it
reuben why marketing tell me a little
bit about your you know why you're doing
marketing
um it's a good question michael so
marketing for me as you said it's an art
it's how it's to get to engage people to
get to educate people to get to attract
people you know i could have done sales
i could have done business development i
could have done many other things i
think i'm equally good at all of them
but marketing for me is really uh you
know getting people engaged
getting them from to go through an
entire journey today it's the art is
ready to understand your buyer from an
initial stage when he's still you know
um looking at research and trying to
understand what's happening in the
domain
getting into his mindset being at the
forefront that you know you're a thought
leader you can help him you can provide
him some value you know without trying
to sell him like in a you know
marketplace or whatever so the art of
b2b is really
engaging and interesting it allows us to
uh go through the entire buyer journey
and get people you know in all places um
understand
a better value proposition for that was
that's the main kind of thing that
excites me interests me to
get people to to get engaged and and
talk to a lot of people be involved with
a lot of people talk to a lot of
companies get them to understand
any company i'm especially cybering
which is like a threat intelligence
leader right and and this domain as you
said the cyber space is so crowded
every day
anyone can be attacked and breach it's
you know it's it's just when it's gonna
happen it's not it if it will happen it
will happen and now how you are prepared
how you're engaged how you build your
defenses around you and you choose the
right propositions for your enterprise
is important for any organization and
is one of those
companies that can help them
incredible so you know i'm coming from
an engineering background and you know
when i think about coding you know i
have a variety of coding languages that
i can play around with and at the end
you know overall architecture you know
it's kind of repetitive and we have the
same best practices that are agreed upon
globally is this the same
holding true for marketing that sort of
there's there are these different
techniques and they're pretty similar
and then you just adjust them to
whatever circumstances how much variety
d or variants do you have as you think
through marketing strategies for
different companies
i i think that in general the strategies
can be similar so you have a set of
strategies that you can think about
where you want to take your company into
for example if you want to build an
account based marketing strategy where
you say i want to understand more deeper
the personas in an account i understand
what interests them what excite them
what makes them tick and i'll start to
bring content that is relevant to them
that makes it in engaging for them and
you start to build a journey towards
that so so you need to understand the
basics marketing has evolved a lot it's
a way you know advanced than many other
domains um you have a lot of things that
you know digital marketing people with
the covid right it's people are not so
much face-to-face meeting anywhere so
you know the sales people can run and
and and and go and meet people as they
used to do before so a there are a set
number of strategies but everybody needs
to look at how they can optimize and
implement and what works best for their
organization so you have to have a clear
and a crisp
mindset about what you want to do how
you understand the organization your
customers how they perceive you how they
want to be perceived by you and then
build your marketing strategy
hope that answered your question i think
that that makes a lot of sense no no
yeah definitely that makes a lot of
sense and so how do you even go about
developing these strategies how do you
know how much of it is you know sort of
trial and error and testing and what is
sort of the process that you go through
as you're saying okay i want to i have
this product and now i want to figure
out how to market it to other
enterprises
yeah so so you build what you call an
ideal customer profile you know you see
who's your target audience
you try to map out the target audience
it can be a mid enterprise a big
enterprise it can be a vertical it can
be
many verticals so so you have to really
be laser focused understand if your
product to who it's relevant and who
will be the first ones that will be
eager to update your product right that
will help you you know be more
do more with your resources like you
know we always like to do more with less
so so it's uh it's it's it will help you
build some kind of uh initial focus then
you need to kind of uh slice and dice
how you're gonna talk to each of your
different key personas if it's the cio
or the siso in the security space the
chief security officer you know so map
out your relevant personas and then you
start to build you know what would be
the ways to kind of reach out to them
how do you generate brand awareness so
you know you can be a small startup with
a five person company or one person
company and you can be a big enterprise
uh you know the you are different in the
you sometimes you are known sometimes
you are not known so taking a company
from an unknown to a known journey is
also a process so that's brand awareness
right so you need to create that brand
awareness you need to kind of build the
right engagement process with the
analysts and uh in the different uh you
know the key analysts like the gardeners
and the foresters that they understand
your value proposition and what you're
offering because they're also talking to
b2b customers right they're engaging
with b2b customers so
you have to build a
first of all the layer of brand
awareness and then you need to go about
saying how can i uh engage better how do
i build my website that talks and and
the language of the customer that he
understands that his journey will be
engaging so so then you said about the
building the infrastructure the basic
infrastructure which is your website the
face to the earth recently we revamped
our website you can look at it much more
engaging much more interesting so we
want to get more people to convert
because they want to learn more they
want to understand they want to see if
you have value proposition that that
appeals to them if i can't within 30
seconds catch their span of attention
i've lost it you know i'm i'm out of the
game
and now if they understand that i have
research that can help them i have
things that can help them and and make
them also be you know
well valued at their organization i got
the attention then it's important to
also look at how you map your peers the
the customer's peers what how they think
about you and engage with them also so
you build a few circles and you start to
build i think the key the heart is
content so you have great content you
keep them engaged and then you get some
kind of dialogue and process which is a
part of the lead generation engine so
starting from brand development to lead
generation it's a whole process that you
need to come look at every bit of it and
see that you cover all the parts of it
you know you can do everything equally
well some is trial and error you know
especially with kovid and with people
being remote now so it's um even more
challenging something which usually you
had conferences people were jumping on a
plane going to an rsa or going to an
infosec in europe or and and meeting
face-to-face but with that gone you have
to be very smart with your content
strategy and your digital strategy
so let's take
cybernt as a as a case study right so
you're facing now
threat intelligence platform one of the
leading in the world the hyper growth
company
and you're thinking about how do i how
do i market this thing how do i market
this to other b2b enterprises and and
explain something that is a little
complicated it's not that trivial
how do you even go about that what are
some what is sort of your thought
process through there
okay
that's uh there are multiple things that
need to be take first of all it needs to
be crisp clear what we do and what value
we can bring so we try to actually come
to the enterprise and very simply say
you know we don't need heavy machinery
no servers involved in the organization
we actually sit on the outside and we
scale you scan your parameter we look at
what's happening what's the threat
landscape beyond your perimeter we look
at all your digital assets we map them
out
very simply very easily and we come back
and we give you very targeted
intelligence you know without
intelligence you're blind right you if
you have intelligence you can be smarter
you can prevent attacks or breaches that
can happen or even are being planned to
happen so you you need to be very well
prepared and having intelligence is a
baseline of that i think that enterprise
get data when you show them like
suddenly you talk to an organization you
show him in a in a demo you talk to him
or you show him like a bunch of league
credentials from his organization out in
the dark web which will in two minutes
somebody will breach him can install a
malware can be a ransomware inside his
organization so
i think they get it i think they get it
and and and people understand that it's
a part now many people need to take the
progression from understanding that it's
really going to help me to to something
that will that will to to
bring it into the organization so that's
a process and usually you know when we
get to that stage we're very successful
in convincing our customers and we have
a very satisfied uh team of people a
bunch of customers because our
intelligence team uh mainly
uh comprised of a lot of analysts from
uh israeli defense forces are very
experienced and have a lot of you know
they go very deep and very intense into
the sources different sources for
intelligence and bring out a lot of
valuable information to support
customers and when you have a happy
customer is ready to speak to another
four customers prospects and tell them
that he's happy so i think you know um
we that's where you know we we kind of
focus our attention into and um bringing
that message to the market making a
available making them aware that
cyberend is here to support them to be a
partner to them not only you know
selling them a platform we don't sell a
platform we bring a service that will
help them if they don't find help on the
service you know we don't they shouldn't
use us but you know most of the people
that come here and that and part of
cyberins family we look at them as a
family and really the analysts also
treat them as a family and offer them
the managed services portion also as
part of that
allows us to really keep our customers
you know with us and help us grow our
cyber and family
fantastic fantastic and so
you know what this world is changing
what i'm what i'm hearing from you a
huge part of this is trust right and
you're only talking about the customer
satisfaction and their vote of
confidence and and your the the
professional analysts that you have it's
a lot about building trust with these
enterprises so that they want to both
you know
have you being a part of their platform
and being sort of their defense
mechanism and that is a crucial part to
the conversion here right
i agree with you i think actually it all
starts with the trust internally so you
know our ceo
and uh it's it's part of the dna that
that we instill in our people we say
first of all let's trust each other
let's you know we look at ourselves as a
as a family you know even though we have
people in the us in
in asia pack in europe still we try to
make it as a family we keep sure that
you know the whatever information we
keep it available to our people so they
understand you know what's happening in
the company what's the progress so we
build internal trust and that internal
trust builds excitement and motivation
and they convey that to our customers to
get them to trust us you know i spoke to
a couple of uh csos
who are customers and ask them why do
you say you know i get so much valuable
intelligence and alerts that after that
i can take real decisive action and even
if i have like multiple platforms that
are providing me i can take that and
come to the to the to the to the board
and the executive team and show them i
took actionable and impacted and
benefited the company so you know that's
the kind of relationship we build and
the trust both internally and externally
also
and so
from your experience now working in the
in the cyberspace and marketing for
quite some time
what are what is perhaps the number one
factor for building this trust is it
more the the personal
touch the the communication with the
company is it more on the technological
side the validations is it the customers
what really is sort of the
the end result here
i think as in many cases it's not one
single thing right so a one you need to
have a group a good platform and a good
way and a good offering right if you
don't have a stable and a solid offering
uh you know whatever trust you build and
whatever relationship you have will not
help you because you need to bring value
to the to the customer so our offering
is very strong and brings a great value
now if you add to that the human factor
the human touch and you that helps us
alleviate our offering right and brings
us with the to build to enhance the
trust and the engagement and the value
that we bring so
both together is a much holistic picture
for the customer and helps him then to
understand the value proposition and and
use our platform and to be a satisfied
customer
right right reuben tell me a little bit
about you know what excites you
in the space
what excites you about your day-to-day
work you know what really what really
gets you going
first of all getting things done i like
to get things done right if i if i get
up in the morning and you know
i don't i don't see that like i have a
full day out of me and i'm get i have
you know
i'm gonna make an impact every day is a
day where i need to make an impact if
it's a small impact or a big impact it
doesn't make a difference so um it's
getting motivated getting excited every
day you go to work or you work remote
doesn't matter wherever you are but you
know sitting with you here excites me
talking with people engaging with people
so what motivates me is really you know
doing things and getting things uh you
know a progress and and achievements so
um that makes me thick okay
i i love it and you know obviously to
continue innovating and being creative
and and understand the strategies that
will again get your customers to trust
you and be excited requires quite quite
a bit of inspiration
where where is your inspiration coming
from
my inspiration comes from you know
many of the great leaders that drove
innovation you know if you look at steve
jobs and you look at
even elon musk you know it's uh it's
taking the the automate of inter
industry and moving it like you know to
a new dimension that that that company
is like uh many times bigger than any of
the other traditional now i have nothing
against traditional automotive but it's
a game changer right so looking at
different leaders that are game changers
reading about them understanding you
know their lifestyle um
keeps me
very very you know a look at them as uh
kind of
where i should be myself and kind of
keep innovation pushing ourselves are we
doing enough can what's the next step we
need to do if it's in marketing or even
pushing our r d team i think that way
even in turn the company we challenge
ourselves all the time to see that we
can keep a step ahead you know what's
the next thing we want to bring to our
customers what's the next feature what's
the next
tool that we can offer them that will
help them make so that those are things
like you know a what keeps uh
innovating and helps us and we draw this
and i draw this inspiration from uh many
of the big leaders that were
much much greater than me anyway
so it sounds like a marketing role
especially in a deep tech company like
cyber and you know it requires quite
quite a bit of product understanding as
well and understanding of the technology
itself to be able to then you know sort
of be the bridging gap between the
customers the sales cycle back to the
product and the development of the r d
to try and even understand and give
feedback of what is actually happening
and where are we
where are we maybe coming in short where
should we be doubling down right yes i i
think definitely you need to understand
the product you need to understand you
know what uh use cases you are covering
in an intensive manner so
are you going deep enough if you are if
you kind of you know if you're looking
let's say the examples of fraud you know
really going deep understand how what is
what are the customers value how do they
get the value how would they you know
get even better so
yes i think you need to understand now
it doesn't mean that you have to be a
developer right if you're it's great but
i i think you know um a deep
understanding helps you understand
better the product and the pain points
of your customer and
then you can also relate your story and
tell it in a better manner to your
customers or potential customers
you know growing up reuben did you know
that you're going to go into marketing
that this is sort of your calling and
that this is your you mentioned that you
have quite a you know
variety of skill sets but was this
something that you always sort of you
know thought through
i knew i love to speak to people and
engage with people and and and learn new
things if it's understanding wine
understanding food and becoming a foodie
so i i kind of uh um
thought it was a natural evolution for
me you know when i started off my career
it started off on in in in high tech
with different companies but uh you know
i kind of started off on a sales and
marketing role and then felt i i felt
more comfortable uh doing marketing you
know that's where i felt i could
express myself better engagement so if
you say if i was when i was a child i
dreamt about marketing maybe not but i
can tell you that i was always kind of
interested in engaging and trying to
lead things and and do new things and
and i think the curiosity then comes and
helps you you know take on whatever part
you take in life for me it was going
through marketing
i love it so i'm a young entrepreneur
looking to start my own business one day
and i don't have any marketing
background but i'm looking to bring some
amazing marketing people what is sort of
one or two pieces of advice you would
give to any you know person starting
their journey in marketing and needs to
think through okay how do we how do we
even learn what how to do this and how
do we become experts and have the
experience that you've had
i think one is understanding uh when
you're coming to a new product or a new
solution that you want to bring to
market i think is understanding
what you are doing what is the what is
the value proposition you bring to your
customer right and and then try to
understand their pain points their
journey are you answering that how can
you help
define it better so understanding well
the product offering you're bringing and
then building your go-to-market strategy
so i think you need to have a
if you're bringing a new marketer on
board he needs to really understand the
full scope of marketing you know as i
said
in a new especially a small company
right because you don't have the luxury
to have more people and get more people
so you know you can you you need to
understand
what what are the pain points i'm
solving what are the messages that i can
help
relieve those pain points for my
customer and then what are the easiest
two three avenues that i can take it to
market and help
build my brand right because i think at
the end of the day it's all about
developing a brand if you're if people
know you are there and you're uh and
you're giving a solution that will help
them and that is a dream for every
marketer
i love it reuben i i want to thank you
so much for for being here 20 minutes go
by so fast every time and i have 10 more
questions that i want to ask you about
marketing uh but i'm gonna have to leave
them for after the episode and i really
appreciate
the time that you've given me and and
your experience is phenomenal and i
can't wait to to see where you take
cyberint and thank you for the time and
effort so stay safe and stay healthy and
thank you thank you michael it was
awesome to talk to you and i'm happy to
answer any questions after this and
anybody you want to me to answer to
take care
[Music]